in Puerto Rico hurricane Irma will reach
Florida here in less than 48 hours
nearly every major city in the state is
a potential target other cities like
Atlanta could also be hit as Irma moves
north one point four million people live
in Florida's mandatory evacuation areas
the governor has ordered all Florida
schools to close so the buildings can be
used as shelters mark Strassmann is on
the coast here in Miami Beach mark good
morning good morning more than 700,000
people here in miami-dade county are
under a mandatory evacuation order and
you can tell that most of them have
taken it seriously take a look this is
South Beach a couple of blocks from the
Atlantic Ocean boarded up close for
business
streets closed to traffic people have
studied the radar and hit the road
hürmüz storm surge could put this
neighborhood in high water and deep
trouble gridlock has gripped roads from
Miami to Orlando as tens of thousands
scrambled to evacuate a Miami Beach
families piled up sandbags trying to
protect their homes from the storm I'm
scared
sherry Schwartz lives a half-mile from
the beach she told us her neighbors are
staying put but she's not I would like
to be in denial but this time I'm taking
heed and getting out on average Miami
Beach sits about 4 feet above sea level
storm surges from early here could reach
3 to 6 feet Governor Rick Scott has
issued evacuation orders across the
state I said but there are still
holdouts like 91 year old Holocaust
survivor Joe sacks I'm still a kid that
like a challenge SEC said he's
uncomfortable moving to a shelter
because he needs medical equipment to
survive at least 11 hospitals and 142
health care facilities have already
closed in Florida we've not seen
anything this ominous since Andrew and
so we're waiting for it along with the
rest of the community
category-five hurricane andrew hit
florida 25 years ago 65 people died and
it cost the state billions of dollars in
damage hurricane
Irma is even bigger in size than
Hurricane Andrew Schwartz worries what
she may come home to find after this
storm I'm afraid that there might not be
much really it's that worrisome just the
size of the storm and the power despite
the mandatory evacuation order many
people here will tell you they're still
deciding whether to go and for them
today is d-day decision day do I stay or
do I go the last place you want to be
during a hurricane is on an open Highway
fully exposed exposed to the beating and
that's where some people can find
themselves if they leave here too late
Jeff